die Zutaten für eine Sauce Hollandaise
kann man an einer Hand abzählen viele
Restaurants greifen allerdings zur
Fertigsoße aus dem Tetrapack
Gutenachtgeschichte kommt jetzt bei
dieser Zutatenliste
Sebastian zeigt wie sich die Industrie
eine buttrige Sauce Hollandaise ganz
ohne Butter zusammentrickst
[Musik]
die Sauce Hollandaise eine klassische
Buttersoße besteht aus Butter Eigelb ein
bisschen Zitrone und Weißwein und ein
paar Gewürzen für die Hollandaise wird
der gelernte Koch Eidotter Salz Pfeffer
und Zitronensaft in einer Schüssel
Butter stabilisiert das Ei und erzeugt
diese besonders cremige Konsistenz die
Butter darf nur im Wasserbad bei
möglichst gleich bleibender Temperatur
langsam zugefügt werden
dabei gilt die Hollandaise darf nicht zu
kalt werden und der 68 Grad wird sie
dickflüssig und schon ab 73 Grad
die Industrie bietet fix und fertige
Soßen an die bewirbt sie in Werbespots
mit viel küchenromantik
den Liter gibt es im Großhandel schon
für 5,48 €. das sind etwa 40 bis 80 Cent
pro Portion wie geht das so günstig
immerhin besteht klassische Sauce
Hollandaise aus Wein frischen Eiern und
Butter lauter teuren Zutaten
gute Nacht Geschichte kommt jetzt bei
dieser Zutatenliste
erste Zutat na raten Sie mal und
Wasser weiß wenn es sich Branntweinessig
Gewürze hefewechselt Aroma dann noch mal
weiß wenn Extrakt noch mal Senf
Senfsamen Branntweinessig Speisesalz
paprikaextrakt auf den Verpackungen
findet Sebastian im Schnitt über 17
Zutaten die Soße von Knorr für die Liste
an mit 23 Zutaten dabei kommt die
original Hollandaise mit vier Haupt
Zutaten aus das kann ich gerade
aussprechen
stabilisatorium Phosphat
aber steht echt so Hollandaise drauf
in echter Sauce Hollandaise steckt viel
Butter so auch in der knorrsoße
die Toni Gourmet arbeitet dagegen mit
Butter rein Fett Verdickungsmittel Ölen
und vor allem Wasser das steht an erster
Stelle
[Musik]
kommen ganz ohne Butter raus
Wahnsinn oder
eine Art Buttersoße ohne Butter mit Öl
ein paar Verdickungsmittel und fertig
wie das funktioniert das Zeichen jetzt
mal für die Soße aus dem Tetrapack
benötigt Sebastian entrahmte Milch
einige Male zur Verdickung Xanthan zum
Gelieren Eigelb und viel Wasser
[Musik]
so viel Zutaten braucht man wenn man
eine Sauce Hollandaise immer griffbereit
haben möchte wenn sie backstabil sein
soll oder auf eine Pizza und und und und
die wird ja überall verwendet was mit
der Hand gemacht überhaupt nicht
funktionieren würde zu das Nummer 1
Sebastian lege setzt auf pasteurisiertes
Eigelb statt auf frisches Ei dazu Milch
und Wasser
und jetzt eine Trilogie von Bindemitteln
hier
Johannesbrotkernmehl
und Xanthan dadurch kann die Soße
aufkochen ohne dass das Eigelb drin
[Musik]
wenn Sie das Riechen würden es riecht
echt extrem
so wo keine Butter drin ist muss Aroma
rein ist doch ganz einfach ne und ohne
Butter
gibt es Öl na klar so wesentlich
günstiger zum Produzieren dafür steht
keine Kuh auf der Weide und man muss die
Sahne so lange geschlagen damit der
Butter drauf wird nee Öl kann schnell
produziert werden und auch in Massen
die Industrie verwendet billiges Palm
Raps oder Sonnenblumenöl die vielen
Zutaten verbinden sich erst bei hoher
Geschwindigkeit
Sebastian lege setzt einen
profi-mix-stab ein
so sollen das besteht als Fertigprodukt
hauptsächlich aus Wasser pflanzlichen
Ölen Verdickungsmitteln und Aromen auch
ohne die klassischen Zutaten wird diese
Mischung als Sauce Hollandaise verkauft
und das ganz legal der Begriff Sauce
Hollandaise ist nicht geschützt es gibt
kein gesetzleitsatz oder ähnliches das
sagt so muss sie zusammengesetzt sein
und es muss Butter enthalten sein in der
Gastronomie sind nur wenige Gerichte
geschützt ein Wiener Schnitzel z.B darf
nur aus Kalbsfleisch bestehen ist es aus
Schweinefleisch muss es Wiener Art
heißen die Sauce darf auch aus dem
Tetrapack kommen und die industriellen
Zutaten müssen nicht einmal angegeben
werden
das muss nicht in der Speisekarte
deklariert sein ich kann natürlich
nachfragen aber die Frage ist auch was
für eine Antwort bekomme ich da denn
selbst wenn ich eine tetrapacksoße noch
mal aufwärme und vielleicht etwas
verfeinere kann ja die Aussage sein die
haben wir hier frisch gemacht da hilft
nur ein geschulter gaum
jemand der schon meine richtige Sauce
Hollandaise probiert hat der weiß ob das
der jetzt Butter drin ist oder ob das
eine mit Öl ist die irgendwie aus der
Packung kommt selbst wenn es nur
irgendwie verfeinert ist doch die
meisten Restaurants scheint das nicht zu
stören Fertigprodukte sind in deutschen
Küchen bereits weit verbreitet in 80 bis
90 Prozent der Restaurants wird bereits
convenience verwendet mindestens 80% der
Restaurants nutzen demnach die Angebote
der Gastronomie Lieferanten der
Platzhirsch ist Metro mit fast 7
Milliarden Euro Umsatz im Jahr dahinter
liegen Transgourmet und Edeka
Transgourmet hat einen Marktanteil von
gut 24 Prozent sie bieten nicht nur
einzelne Produkte an sondern liefern
gleich direkt ins Restaurant
convenience Saucen sind der
Verkaufsschlager der Industrie
eimerweise werden sie fix und fertig für
wenige Euro angeboten sie glänzen durch
eine lange Zutatenliste voller
Zusatzstoffe
im Angebot Soße balkanarts mit zuckern
und Süßungsmitteln
Schaschliksoße oder Jägersoße mit 19%
Champignons und 2% Karotten
hauptbestandteil ist verdicktes Wasser
die Zubereitung ist denkbar einfach
Aufwärmen in der Mikrowelle und ab auf
den Teller so sparen Restaurants viel
Zeit und Geld
und die Forschung in dem Bereich
convenience es wahnsinnig gewachsen also
die stecken sehr viel Geld in die
Entwicklung weil das einfach ein großer
Markt das sei es im Supermarkt für zu
Hause und da eben auch in den großen
Gewinden für Gastronomie
dabei ist selbst die komplizierte
Hollandaise einfach zuzubereiten
Sebastian lege verrät den Trick für zu
Hause
[Musik]
brauchen wir nicht nein
wir machen eine schnelle Hollandaise mit
frischen Zutaten ratzfatz
100%ige gelingt Garantie hier Essig und
Gewürze
[Musik]
verlassene Butter
drei Eigelb
ein bisschen Salz
man könnte jetzt noch andere Gewürze
hinzugeben und und und wie man mag
umrühren
die Mischung füllt Sebastian lege in
einen ganz normalen Sahnespender noch
ein paar Tropfen Zitronensaft dazu
[Musik]
dann verschließen und kurz im Wasserbad
erwärmen
schütteln und fertig ist die lockere
Rollers
sie ist richtig luftig sie ist perfekt
gebunden und da die auch nicht so schwer
durch die kleinen Luftbläschen schmilzt
sie gleichmäßig im Mund und wie Sie
sehen können sie bleibt perfekt stehen
so einfach geht das